I don't know if we're ready to pull this
up but I want to pull it up because it's
my favorite thing
um about this interview is you dancing
on Tick Tock you're a hit I don't know I
don't know
because I'm an idiot are you serious no
I am not with this is my stupid I'm not
even going to Miley
let's do it okay here we go
flowers
[Applause]
[Music]
about it it's literally like I didn't
think I could love you more and I
watched this and I was like it's the
best part is you're like you're like
this looks like a good spot and then you
go for it and then you're like maybe
this and it's I that's literally me at
my house I love dancing I own it all the
time on this show when I'm home alone I
dance in my house and I think even in
front of my kids they think I'm nuts but
I love dancing it looks like you feel
good when you do it I had a fun time but
I'm a
yeah I love that video I was like we're
showing it
um and her whole Instagram feed it takes
two hours it's it's brilliant and all of
it is she has the one part that's doors
it's just doors you don't want to miss
out on the door
I don't even know if you know this but
you have like blown up on Tick Tock like
literally yeah
what is tick tock
I know I get it but like you are like
it's it's insane everybody's like did
you see the video and I'm like I did
it's incredible and you I think it's and
first of all I love doors what are they
like different doors all over yeah I
like the doors yes Oh I thought you
meant like actual Outdoors yeah I used
to do that in Spain when I walked out in
Spain I used to take pictures because
all the doors they're amazing that's
right yeah and I'm obsessed with them
and wine
[Music]
[Applause]